can I went to welcome to this video
playing male anguish who is that this is
the guy still vision crop about okay and
I'm not sure form where there is booked
just go to message them ok ok so now i
can play saudi six-year by mark we see I
want to do here maybe get into the
Benoni I don't like especially I think
once the take cream interesting yeah
this is a well known position type out
of the thing out of them other back King
Finian turn your white um can present
this kind of position for a long time
interesting ok this one the note have
three probably ought to d3 both make
some sense see what he does to stop any
b5 business go to harry mickey six
square which you can you cover up with
this but then I still have before ideas
objectively speaking this is just pretty
good for white unless there's some
miracle 95 or so that could work
actually so g3 I can always go to g2
what is he doing on the f6 I can also
play okay one and also good this one
first yeah so if I go clean b3f and just
attack the pause hope how does it cover
it quindi for maybe it's not so good
hm this is a kind of position that I
would love to have in a tournament game
against from GM that would mean lot no
suffering for black because they are the
likelihood that you bet you lose to some
cheap trick is relatively low and yeah I
mean he has bad pieces all over the
place night on age 69 27 and the whole
pawn structure is terrible for example
minor piece ending without looks and
queens I just go before and win on the
queenside the whole Queen side would
fall apart yeah I don't okay I mean
taking aim is good I don't know if I
want to play gypsy three and trade this
as well this is not quite clear I'm sure
him I don't want to trade the bishop
with the bishops III
tweenty tweenty one tweenty to this is
this would be good i can try i mean
maybe he allows it
yeah taking money to is impossible yes
to try night you form but I have g4 then
also not easy to handle taking only two
as more playable but that ending is
really bad unless they overlook some
some tricks or just don't understand it
don't they don't understand it it should
be absolutely unplayable good g45 or the
sequel g5 himself
native to this
wow what King a3 Bishop d3 resides let
me sex on g5 or something what am I
looking comedy nothing but actually take
the two edges doesn't work i mean this
ending type is very known for four cent
for four decades there are all games
from the 70s by putting is key and and
so on woman this is which is an
unplayable structure i get to the
tournament games exactly the same ending
ok again to get to the wife five can
also play be four first that's no reason
not to cannot take it back and you take
26 is also a goner ok
yeah just 26 time morning check oh I
didn't see the check I was a bit silly i
was a bit silly to allow i just thought
he has no square at all check check
check check check check check check
blank resign that was a strange game I
really bet that sets of story told
dozens of times on this ending and
simply clean takes it to its not
playable just won't play on it its
structures the gray as old as old as the
Kings Indian right get g45 and before
and both the engine is actually pretty
generous there
2.7 I think that's more or less lost
with good technical plane now g4 and a I
think you should do some allowing g5 is
basically giving up Oh Bishop e3 a mess
because of some kind of tactic when we
should see 11 set 0 so i have to looking
at three first okay but i don't quite
understand what is what about what if I
is 0 we have to check hi Scott a check
okay yeah it's a shame yeah then okay
I'm king of three first now everything
is back in order Jen and white wins yeah
this is this is already pretty nice but
can't you just trade it down to two I
thought you have to go this I mean I
wasn't sure this is a good move man 45
king of eight g5 and then taking right
King King protects the Queen this is the
thing okay so this is what I have to do
where's pretty nice as well and remember
that the whole structure is pretty nice
anyway jenn jenn mann vs. they're here
this is one opportunity i didn't didn't
think about there should be three I was
just happy to get this in because its
structural wife is very nice yeah I get
this and so on but ok but should be
three as a good point okay and now it's
basically over yeah okay guys thanks for
watching